and for me like i've never been a pet
lover and i you know and i know that
hurts some people to hear but
i i grew up in an environment where you
didn't have i didn't nobody had a
[ __ ]
pet when i was young okay
you know i saw a blind kid one time get
chased by two bats that's really the
first experience i ever had with animals
and that [ __ ] is i
and then i i got attacked by dogs on one
of my birthdays i got attacked by cats
on one of my birthdays a cat came off
this roof one time of a
um camper and [ __ ] got me
right around my clavicle when we were
about to go to the river one time
couldn't even go
you know how to get rabies tetanus shots
all that
so i haven't had good experience and
nobody in my neighborhood had nobody had
a pet
nobody had a [ __ ] p-e-t a pet is
something you
touch that is an animal okay people had
animals
you know they had that dog that live
over there by wellington's house
by danny wellington's have you seen that
dog
people are like is that danny's dog [ __ ]
no that ain't danny's dog
okay that dog's from somewhere else that
dog could be from nebraska
it's mixed the dog is mixed you know it
looks kind of half
you know maybe half scottish half
african-american
and that thing's out there [ __ ]
people up by danny wellington's
that ain't no that's nobody's dog i
remember the first time i ever saw a pet
indoors and that was a pet that's a dog
you can touch
that doesn't it's not gonna um you know
uh that's not gonna that's not gonna
try and attack you or wrangle you or get
some blood out of your body with its
teeth
yeah we didn't have all that so when i
see these people come
you know when i see you know and i'm in
the safe confines of this
of this ranch man it just made me for
the first time in my life i kind of felt
what it was like to be an animal lover
really and you know and that shows me
that a lot of times it's just about
it's just about uh that safety
feeling that safety around animals and
feeling
i guess you know i grew up in such fear
of him that i wasn't able to love it's
hard to love from a place of
fear it's really really hard and that's
one thing i've even found i'm not trying
to get emo here but one thing i found
about myself as a person
that when i was a child i was i must
have been so fearful as a child
that it was hard for me to learn about
love because i couldn't you it's
really hard to love from a place of fear
because love is just it's a lot of trust
love is just as much trust as you can
put together
i mean it's just a really fancy fancy
buffet of trust
you know you got a little bit of trust
pudding and you got some you know uh
you know you got some trust ruffles and
you got some trust truffles and you got
trust flakes and
trust cracklings over here and then
you've got the bowl
trust and the baked trust and the murder
murder trust
and that's that trust buffet that's love
but man when you don't have that growing
up and you feel fearful
then it's hard to love things it's hard
to love people it's hard to love
yourself really but that's what happened
to me with them animals
you know every time i went outdoors it
was [ __ ] you know gang gang
son who wants a piece of daddy
you know you know trying to punch at
these crows that were trying to attack
us or
you know people you know dogs coming at
us
you know not to mention the lice belt
don't even tell me i didn't grow up in
the lice belt
you know next thing you know you're
walking with a friend next to you know
he hits the dirt
and he's scratching his head you don't
know what happened you think invisible
lightning got him no it didn't
no it didn't that's lice
and that's the devil's invisible
crawling lightning and that's head lice
and so it just you know it was hard to
it was hard to love animals
when you couldn't trust them because i'm
gonna be honest if people want to say
all animals
all animals aren't trustworthy and all
that let's don't get into that [ __ ]
okay some of these animals are out there
just trying to catch a
just get that next hit to buy that next
gram
okay to cop that next piece of ass not
every animal
is nice you know if you remember roger
rabbit
and they have those three or four
weasels those sneaky weasels trying to
trying to bang that chick with the red
hair yeah
remember scrooge mcduck the beagle boys
they're dogs dude yeah and they were
bank robbers and i know you're like oh
those are drawings i know they're
drawings but they're based on real life
you idiot
and that's what i'm saying not all
animals are great but when you don't
trust them you don't have that truth
good evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or watch
this one watch this one watch this one
watch this one